one of your mini books can is right time
right and so you say that the world can
be divided into two people productive
people and non productive people and
that you say productive people have a
love affair with time so I would love to
know what makes someone on the right
side of time whereas what's makes
someone sort of time as our enemy
well yeah that's a very good question
and put in a very intelligent way that
makes it hard to figure out the handle
on it because time is time is this it
doesn't really exist I mean time is a
human construct we we created time
squirrels and you know Chipmunks don't
have much idea of time you know the Sun
rises and the Sun Goes Down and they
know that rains but they don't think the
way we do we're you know they don't keep
track of their birthdays for example
like only humans do that and it's
unfortunate because you know you're only
as old as you think you are that's the
way a squirrel looks at it and nobody's
arguing with the squirrel about it you
know but but humans know better and
people some people look at time as the
enemy and some people look at as a
friend there's an old Spanish saying
this is there's more time than life
which I always thought was a wonderful
way of looking at it because it's that
sort of productive person would say
there is more time than life and another
Spanish or Italian saying says that life
is law is is short but wide and that's
another way that productive looking at
it like people say how could you do as
much stuff as you do well because that's
what I do I don't do anything else yeah
and I used to give classes on time
management and do a lot of studies on it
in fact write time is filled with time
management theories and one of the
things I noticed about people is they
had no idea where their time went and
and they go I don't know where you get
find all the time and I would say like I
don't know where you lose it I mean we
all have the same amount of time and I
go how much time do we have by the way
the hours are in a week and like two out
of ten people can answer that question
right off the top of their heads because
they've never really multiplied 24 times
seven and realize exactly how many hours
there are in a week and so everyone has
the same amount of time so what I would
do in a time management class at UCLA or
elsewhere as I would say let's keep
chart your time this this week I just
want you to make a chart of what you do
with your time and let's come in and
talk about it next week when we come
back together and they come back in and
and that was before I asked them how
many hours or in a week
I would wait for the third week to ask
that question and they would some people
would come in with ninety eight hour
weeks and some people would come in with
sixty-two hour weeks nobody seemed to
agree in general how many hours there
were in a week because the hours they
gave me didn't add up they didn't make
sense you know they'd say I sleep like
six hours a week but it turned out in
the third week of analysis that there
actually I mean six hours a day it would
turn out that actually they were
sleeping 10 hours a day
they just were telling themselves they
slept six hours a day how much time do
you spend talking on the telephone
so most people thought they spent maybe
15 minutes a day when in fact they might
it might be an hour every day but
they're spending on that and watching
television of course some people were
saying that they only spent maybe an
hour a day when they were released
spending three hours a day and but but a
productive person knows exactly how long
it takes to do something like when I
write a screenplay or a book I tell you
how many hours it takes to to do it and
so I know that I can get it done in a
certain amount of time I mean Agatha
Christie
apparently wrote as many as ten books a
year she had to use four or five pen
names because she just kept writing when
you think about it writing is a function
of how fast do you type you know because
if you have you're always say in my
writing book including that one I always
say if you don't if you make it a rule
not to sit down to write before you know
which you're going to write then you'll
never waste any time and you'll never
have writer's block
so simply don't sit down until you know
what you're gonna write then it's just a
matter of how fast can you type so it's
better to be walking along the beach
thinking about the structure of your
story than it is to be wasting a lot of
time sitting in front of the computer
typing stuff and throwing it away and
all that stuff just figure it all out in
your head
and well what if I forget it well guess
what if you forget it that's probably
good
you're forgetting forgettable things you
won't forget it when it starts getting
really good because then it'll do what
Faulkner said it'll start haunting you
and you won't be able to forget it and
then you'll just write it down William
Saroyan was asked once how long it took
him to write the human comedy because
somebody had told the journalist that it
took in with three days a love drug
story and he said no I took me all my
life to write it I just took me three
days to type it out and and that's so if
you're productive you've already figured
out that there are certain things that
are completely unproductive such as
sitting in front of a blank screen
trying to figure out what to put down
next and other ways to do things that
make you productive and productive
people don't waste their time as I said
when it comes to waiting you don't wait
you just do something else you what I
call it rotate from one thing to another
so that you still have you have new
energy constantly all day cause you're
switching activities and when you switch
to a new activity you have new energy
just because of that but you're also
pulling energy from the previous
activity that's kind of pulling you back
and wanting you to do more on it but
that's good instead of listening to it
and going back and doing more on the
previous activity it's better to have
that kind of little anxiety going on
there because then the next time that
activity gets a chance at your time
it'll be ready and it'll be more
productive during that time compartment
so I think that's the whole difference
is between productive and unproductive
people have never figured out how to use
time they don't even
know how to measure time and they
confuse they confuse things I mean there
are two functions in life or two
entities that we deal with one is time
and the other is work and one of them is
it is eternal and and timeless and
endless and the other one is not and but
people get it wrong the one that's
timeless and endless and eternal is work
not time unless your guide you know but
if you're not guide then guess what you
have a limited amount of time and the
only problem is you don't know what the
limit is but that doesn't matter because
you just have to operate anyway but
what's infinite is work because good
work produces more work and so does bad
work right so no matter what kind of
work you're doing it keeps going and you
cannot manage it therefore because it's
a given that you can't manage an
infinite thing but you can't manage
something that is finite and that's time
so managing time is what we have to do
and let's say if you're writing a book
and you know that you type seven pages
an hour at least then you give yourself
one hour every day to write your book
well at the end of a hundred days you've
got you know how many pages 700 pages
right so it's it's not complicated to
figure it out
but you have to manage the right thing
you're managing your time because the
work will happen only if you give it
time to attend it to it and what happens
to the people procrastinate because they
they think they're trying to manage the
work and they they don't know that you
can't manage to work like I'm going to
get this book done if it takes me all
summer and then nothing happens they
don't do it that isn't what you should
do you need to say I am going to work
from 7:00 to 8:00 every morning you know
without fail 4 X 5 days a week it's
better than 7 days a week because your
brain revolts when you make it stop
something that it's actually enjoying so
if you make it stop have
the fifth day it's very upset and it
spends the whole weekend thinking about
the project and it's really raring to go
on Monday when you start again whereas
if you keep it going
it'll get worn out and it'll get bored
eventually because that's what brains do
so that's so productive there's two
kinds of productive people to you know
the unproductive ones let's not talk
about I mean they have their own thing
going and I hope they're enjoying life
but productive people are divided into
two kinds and those are the happy ones
and the unhappy ones the unhappy ones
are the ones who've never figured out
the psychology of creativity and so they
are constantly surprised by it and upset
by it and that's why you have Virginia
Woolf and Hemingway and you know Sylvia
Plath offing themselves at the end
because they'd never figured it out
they've never figured out that at the
end of a project they're gonna get
depressed and they're going to go into
this postpartum depression that they may
never come out of but if if you're on
the other side of the thing the happy
productive person you figured that out
already so what do you do before you end
a project you start another project and
then you can't wait to get into the new
project so you don't mind finishing the
first project so you've eliminated
postpartum depression and that's simply
because you figured out how your
creative mind works which is what
writers time is all about and that's
what I mean by you know productive happy
productive versus unhappy productive
people you don't have to be miserable
and suicidal to be a writer you can be
perfectly happy by knowing your system
and not letting it do it to you
you